karen es una mamá que así como las demás
entró en la guerrilla de las farc cuando
tenía 14 años y hoy en día hace parte de
lo que llaman los reincorporados desde
la firma de los acuerdos de paz en el
2016 y viene un espacio territorial en
el sur de colombia esos lugares han sido
creados para acompañar la reinserción de
los ex combatientes en la guerra pues
no era tan
tan cómodo como ahora en ese tiempo no
podíamos tener niños no era permitido
para mi proceso ha sido un paso muy
importante el hecho de ser mamá porque
tengo a mi hijo que lo que más yo
anhelaba y quiero en estos momentos
con 33 años de edad esta madre soltera
no se arrepienta de haberse
desmovilizado desde su regreso a la vida
civil volvió a estudiar y dedica la
mayor parte de su tiempo a su hijo
steven yo para mi hijo quiero todo lo
mejor
comenzando que lo primero que estudie
para que él no vaya a no
camino equivocado
una de las dificultades que encuentran
los exguerrilleros es la inserción
profesional
la reunión este día las mujeres del
estrecho se reúnen alrededor de tatiana
excomandante y hoy líder del grupo para
reflexionar sobre la apertura de un
comercio para la zona pensáramos en una
panadería gracias a los reincorporados
siguen cobrando el salario mínimo
colombiano aproximadamente 250 dólares
buscan desarrollar proyectos productivos
a largo plazo la falta de oportunidades
profesionales es lo que empujó a los
desmovilizados de monte redondo en el
norte del departamento a marcharse del
espacio territorial en el 2016 eran unos
250 excombatiente en vivir aquí hoy en
día apenas un 40 trabajando por lo
general en las fincas de los alrededores
a algunos kilómetros de aquí ricardo
hace parte de los que se fueron de monte
redondo para armar un proyecto agrícola
su finca se encuentra sobre un terreno
alquilado por la comunidad campesina de
los alrededores acompañado por una
decena de ex combatientes crían peces
este es el alimento que comen los
pescados diariamente ricardo vivía en la
ciudad antes de entrar en la guerrilla
donde pasó 13 años de su vida a los 42
años tuvo que aprender un nuevo oficio
ahorita con el proyecto pues hay un
ingeniero agrícola que viene a
visitarnos cada cada semana él nos deja
las recomendaciones pues nosotros
aprendemos bastante pues esa es la idea
no la mayoría de los fondos que
financian la reincorporación de los
excombatientes viene de la comunidad
internacional en el 2018 la llegada al
poder de un gobierno conservador hostil
a los acuerdos de paz ha complicado el
proceso de reinserción de los ex
guerrilleros a pesar de todo el
desarrollo de proyectos comunitarios
como este es una manera de seguir la
lucha estamos convencidos de que de que
por aquí tenemos que lograrlo que lo que
no logramos con las armas y por ese lado
vamos
pues por la legalidad pues es complicado
pero no aprenden
no pues hay que ser para delante qué
emoción
la gente de la entidad todavía no es
rentable pero lo que más preocupa hoy en
día a sus miembros es el asunto de la
seguridad ricardo nunca sale sin su
escolta el esquema es por el sistema de
que viene sucediendo que en colombia ya
van como 300 reincorporados asesinados
nos venimos dando cuenta desde que de
que nuestra primera necesidad ahora es
que nos garanticen la seguridad que nos
garanticen la vida
y pues eso le corresponde al estado la
vida milton casi la pierde en el 2018
este ha incorporado instalado en un
barrio popular de popayán escapó a un
atentado ejecutado por dos sicarios en
moto mientras se movilizaba en su
vehículo pues emprenden ais para
encontrarme
yo me alcanzo a tirar así después de eso
puede ser es que entró un potrero y aquí
ellos vuelven al coma los más o menos
minutos allí es como estaba si estaba
muerto estaba yo para cuando no llegaron
encontraron lejos la investigación sobre
el ataque contra milton como la mayoría
en esos casos apuntando a los ex
miembros de la farc no ha avanzado y no
se sabe quiénes son los autores frente a
este peligro de los grupos que controlan
ciertas regiones en disputas y que han
matado a muchos reincorporados varios ex
combatientes han decidido instalarse en
las ciudades donde se sienten más
seguros pues no hay tanto como es el
dominio territorial digamos que en los
campos si hay grupos de distintos
nombres que tienen ese control
territorial en el departamento del cauca
la producción de coca y la existencia de
otras actividades ilícitas ponen la
situación muy confusa para alejarse de
esas zonas peligrosas
milton en sus camaradas ha montado una
cooperativa de producción de café en la
periferia de la ciudad gracias a la
prima la cual tiene acceso cada
exguerrillero para la creación de un
proyecto profesional pudieron comprar el
terreno plano
aquí nos sentimos más propios con más
autonomía
como como parte de la cooperativa como
socios y poder mirar un desarrollo
económico y con esto poder cumplir parte
de las expectativas que tenemos
todos los reincorporados de romário los
excombatientes ahora contratan a los
campesinos de los alrededores para que
les ayude durante la temporada de
cosecha un gesto fuerte para ellos y
nuestro trabajo de inversión social
y seguimos seguimos en la misma lucha
esa lucha está lejos de haber acabado
cinco años después de la firma de una
paz que sigue frágil